[Music]
ah
yeah it's it's monday so that's cool
hey did you catch the big brie larson
stream no i didn't
bro it's really cool i'm sorry i'm i'm
afraid i missed that one you didn't you
didn't catch the brie larson stream no i
did not
oh dude she's just like us bro she plays
video games
i did this crazy thing for the first
time in a long time
where i spent most of the weekend
outside in the world
i know i know it's [ __ ] gross but um
yeah i i had no clue of any internet
goings on all weekend and honestly quite
frankly it was pleasant
dude she killed a dude she was playing
video games yeah
she what she needs to be killing us some
squats because she has no ass
she oh you don't understand my friend i
actually stumbled upon it this morning
when i was doing daily larson is that
miserable in the
marvel movie captain marvel mike we've
covered her
yeah we've covered her that broad
yeah look at this dude look how cool
just like regular you know she's like
she's like everybody else look at that
look at that most people most people
most people play their games on a 30 000
italian couch can i ask you can i ask a
question sure
how is this how did this five get famous
that's what i've been talking about too
i've been i played some of her videos
this morning and i was looking at him
like man
i mean a lot of makeup magic and stuff
when you really see her she's all right
she's she's not even all right to be
honest like and i'm not trying to be
like
you know uh some kind of like elitist
like oh yeah i wouldn't [ __ ] her like
not like on that but i mean
you are a little bit no i mean you would
but i mean
she's not this we're talking about
hollywood dude
when she was asked by another celebrity
and i believe it was lily singh
asked her one of her things do you uh
what is you
what's your favorite video game she
answered
nintendo
and what's she playing fortnight no
she's playing some dodgeball game
sponsored by ea
like it's it's it's it's just playing on
the streets it's a straight up
uh transactional thing yeah this is just
a commercial
it's just a commercial um and it's just
you know she's playing there and and she
had
to her credit she had a live chat she
also had 500 mods
but she did have a live chat 500 mods i
believe it too yeah she had 500 mods and
uh there there's there was
a lot of people going in and out of the
chat you know wait a minute so
what's the point of dodgeball if you
have a superpower that can
make the ball go away look man i don't
know
i just know it's a switch game and i
know that she's just like you and me
because she plays video games
and if we're playing dodgeball how come
there's no kids getting tortured
uh she was playing with other two other
twitch streamers
that were you know with her like you
know just kind of globbing off of her
little fame
wow sounds interesting it's not
it's like you pointed out too she's on a
[ __ ] 30 thousand dollar couch
that is by the way that couch is not
available in ashley holm store
oh it's not that's like mail order it
comes
from italy yeah it literally comes from
carthage
yeah yeah like you go that's a real
place still
i don't even know it's made out of
italian leather and the inside is just
elephant bones
yeah and then and the material is the
skin of
children and check it out bro yes
she also gives really good commentary
like yes and
wow so she doesn't even talk to anybody
she doesn't read the chat i tell you
that guys
i'm going to skip around it's your
commentary so you can see your cool
commentary sorry i forgot that we were
gold again i
got scared oh you got him and i just hit
this guys i threw it over him
this guy's afk um oh he's afk he's being
attacked
gamer
and who's she playing with who are these
other two other two other twit uh
to uh sekunu and
brook abc pre-approved twitch streamers
correct they're pre-approved twitch
streamers
that are on her team and she's playing
with them it's sponsored by ea
and they also had to make sure this
isn't a product placement
but you know like you know when you play
a video game you know like you play
video game
you normally have the console sitting
next to you on the table and not by your
tv
the switch is also right next to her to
make sure that has to be
facing the camera right so you know what
she's playing on
nice i don't know you're the thing so
that was her first live stream and i
think it went really well
like her career is doing great right so
she wasn't reading
she wasn't reading the the comments
obviously somebody was probably in there
you know doing all the stuff
uh i don't know who these people are and
so so again whatever
brie larson is like us is my point she
likes playing video games
you know um she she sits indian style on
on the chair she wears shoes on her
streams
because nobody wants your weird
disgusting feet i mean she is just like
us
in that i believe her career is now
about at the same level yeah
what are you doing well what happened
with brie larson is a funny story
because
they remember when brie larson first
came in to play captain marvel right
like that's
that's a huge role right and it was
they they they were trying to make her
be the next because they knew that they
knew that robert downey jr was retiring
from
from the marvel movies and they were
banking on brie larson on my life
so they thought she was going to be the
new like
robert downey jr of of of marvel
so what happened is her movie came out
and her movie was remember her movie was
so bad that they changed
this we talked about on the show they
changed the rotten tomatoes rating
system
you know to make it you had to show a
ticket because because they were saying
white males
i don't make movies for white males i
don't care what they think remember that
whole rant she went on
so because of that her movie did so
poorly
the ending of avengers end game was
supposed to have brie larson and a lot
more but then
she was just in for a little tiny part
of it and now they realize
okay she definitely can't carry a
franchise you know
because she's terrible and it really has
a lot to do with how she acts
in in real life like she's just just a
[ __ ] unlikable
just you know but the thing is like
so they didn't i mean who what i don't
understand is right
if i was trying to replace robert downey
jr
and i met brie larson i would know in
one meeting oh yeah
that this ain't the one like and it's
not
just because she sucks which she does
but you're filling
some very big shoes you know this is
like in the 90s if
if they fired stone cold steve austin
and they're like but don't worry folks
we got steve blackman we're pushing
steve blackman
now look i like steve black by the way
steve blackman
very solidly in my boys stable oh yeah
okay yeah i'm a steve blackman fan
but it's like okay you can't just show
up monday and go
oh yeah austin's gone steve blackman
like people would just go what really
we're doing this
like robert downey jr is one of the most
likable charismatic guys in hollywood
he's very well liked and he's
you know he's got the [ __ ] the the
the redemption arc
he's got all that [ __ ] well here's what
happened escaped from prison once
like that's how cool robert downey jr is
well here's what happened with her okay
be when she got the captain marvel role
she wasn't being publicly super woke
like she was still kind of a nobody
right after she got the role
is when she started being really really
really [ __ ] woke about
her [ __ ] and women empowerment and this
i was watching another video of hers and
in the middle of it like she
she was saying she she was saying like
oh yeah you know sometimes like you know
i get really
i get really tired thank god there's
this app called brain dot fm she was
doing like a live read we took we do
live reads too so don't get me wrong but
i'm not gonna sit here and pretend like
it just came you know
naturally uh and uh yeah so
so she she's [ __ ] my like [ __ ]
pretty larsen's sitting there going like
you know when i'm cat
you know when i take off my cape and i'm
no longer captain marvel
i like to go home kick back and log into
my bookie
did you just have to do it all these i
want to tell you about my pillow
so just we'll move on here which is
really quick i wanted to see some more
of her commentary
oh wait kind of
we only need one more she's not talking
she's just playing and not talking
this is what you do when you're hungover
yeah right you just play video games
quietly
oh yeah oh yeah the flamingos
yeah look at those styles
we just look so cool you know
by the way i like that she's not even
interacting with the people who are
trying to make the stream interesting
and talk right
like the two twitch streamers that know
what they're doing are like trying to
talk and
larson's like not saying anything like
you're not even saying anything back to
them
but you know this is good they probably
paid her like 50 grand to do that
and she didn't have to do anything